venir beaucoup et puis on peut respecter
les anciens je pense que je vais plutôt
pour être exact ringardisé qui a fait la
meilleure vannes cette année est bien
cuit trophée de la meilleure ban
c'est lui jean michel mr et le gagnant
de l'année et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
ça nous pose un problème que jean-michel
mère sortent quelques bonnes vannes
alors il ya énormément de déchet mais
c'est justement l'enquète de ba ba du
jour pensez vous que l'humour de jean
michel maire fait de l'ombre à jean luc
lemoine pour moi la réponse est non mais
jean michel maire y croit dur comme fer
n'est ce pas jean lui tout à fait on
ressent le paravent aussi ma semaine de
chacun non mais il se prend vraiment
pour le sniper de l'émission ouais et
laisser jean luc faire mais vous êtes un
très bon élève
regardez lui c'est jean michel mr plus
connu sous le nom d'urnes ou dur marc ou
encore de l'autre kong depuis de
nombreuses années cet ancien reporter de
guerre qui a fait le tour du monde
entier est devenu un chroniqueur
indispensable touche pas à mon poste
comme il aime à le dire il est rentré
dans l'amour dans le moule
il a même développé un certain sens de
l'humour seulement voilà de l'autre côté
de la table ça ne passe pas
jean luc lemoine rit jaune depuis peu
l'humoriste créateur des quatre tiers
est également féru de déguisements se
retrouve dans une situation délicate
en effet il est désormais en concurrence
avec jean michel merle homme à l'humour
d'une grande finesse vous l'aurez
compris l'humour à un nouveau visage
alors pensez vous que l'humour de jean
michel maire fait de l'ombre à jean luc
lemoine sur cette séquence
jean luc lemoine at-il bandé et surtout
pourquoi jean michel mr méthyle des
costumes qui lui vont comme un gland
autant de questions auxquelles
l'inspecteur ngaba va tenter de répondre
alors jean-michel dit la vérité
est-ce qu entendez-vous fait de l'ombre
à jean agent lui oui alors oui mais je
l'admiré beaucoup et pire on pour
respecter les anciens je pense que je
vais plutôt pour être exact ringardisé
succès c'est l'humour c'est le style
peur à l'ancien moi c'est du style
moderne et sociale c'est comme ça qu'est
ce qu'on a vu c'est le mollet c'est ce
que je vous rappelle ce que je me dis
que des gens dans la rue les jolies
d'accord j'ai compris accord mais qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous parler français
écoutez je pense que il a raison et la
raison ils inventer quelque chose
une nouvelle forme de sniping on va dire
c'est à dire que normalement un sniper
c'est quelqu'un qui a un fusil de
précision qui tirait qui fait mouche lui
fait à la mitraillette
donc il en faut par tous et de toutes il
ya une qui touche c'est à dire que c'est
tabou résumé jean michel et j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour lui et je vous
laisse pas place bien volontiers non
merci on admire beaucoup je suis admis
merci banos si moi aussi je voulais un
beau coup vous ai je fait sur noireau
jcr unique et officiel ces policiers
très bien
oui c'est un beau fixe à picoler
[Musique]